[Music]
maybe if you stopped eating chili you
wouldn't accidentally fart during our
interrupts oh my god don't do it and
then blame me hi
that's Mary Kosh and mahooty yeah it is
didn't you just say before this you're
like oh I should change his back it's
getting annoying yeah but then you know
yeah you're so creative if you knew the
shop is Resnick's and evil
we're playing through every single
resident evil game well numbered and a
few otherwise and now we're on to QA
check and done we're redoing them now we
went through one through seven did a
couple bonuses now we're going back
around again yep we're recording the
night before you fly to San Francisco
for GDC yeah I think the next time we'll
be in San Francisco is right before e3
really yep okay and you'll be in PAX
East won't you yeah I'm going to pack
see you I assume you're going to taxis
yeah we should meet up then while you're
there
yeah we talked about this I want you to
do the rumble with me please I don't
know we'll see
don't leave me alone with those crazy
people
I remember what we need to do now the
answer is nothing I've been to many a
packs with no no no just show I'm
talking about in Resident Evil chat this
game right now exists oh I'm going down
the hole that's what we're doing alright
hey yeah to the whole uh someone told me
to organize my thing again I forget how
tap the touchpad right
cuz I have all this I have to high high
grade gunpowder's and we thought we only
had one but I have to so I can make
submachine gun ammo which we didn't yeah
I don't know I'm just telling you what I
learned since we last played which is I
have more gunpowder than I thought
I do have four acid rounds one flame
round I have a bunch of first-aid sprays
I've been avoiding using all first-aid
sprays and I've been using the triple
triple herbs RGB I would not worry about
ammo right now you've got twenty six
handgun rounds seven eight spark shot
rounds and forty two submachine guns
nothing to sneeze at
I think you're fine is that what I'm
doing in the hole that's what I want to
know because like maybe I don't want to
use the spark rounds in the hole maybe I
want to use submachine gun rounds in the
hole are there dogs in the hole that's
really tops I don't even think you need
the spark shot but but you have a lot of
decent of handgun ammo that'll work too
that's thirty shots no it's not yes it
is you don't need to kill them any
zombies at this part but you need a gun
I'd say just bring the handgun and the
if it'll make you feel better get rid of
the spark shot and then bring like a few
flame or acid grenades go ahead all
right you have my permission
sounds like we're in agreement then well
you have my permission
welcome checked because you should shut
up so I'm taking handgun shut up now
answer my question what question
handgun submachine gun grenade launcher
grenade grenade grenade that's it
bringing acid rounds instead of that one
flame another thing that's gonna do
that's a good also I would save right
after this just be so you don't have to
do all this again
should I bring like one first aid spray
because I have a full heal but should I
have two folios I just bring bring a
green herb with you you don't need to
pull heals I got a knife all right now
I'm gonna save how's Portland it's
awesome it's so nice it's like spring
here and I haven't had a winner in seven
years can you [ __ ] believe that I
even had a winner in seven years because
I lived in Brisbane Australia and they
don't really have winter like they have
a winter but it doesn't snow or it's not
cold and then I went to San Francisco no
winner no cold and then I came to
Portland and it was winter it was wild
and I was like this is winter and then
now it's spring and I'm enjoying spring
because I went through a winner and I
think what I realized is is much like
all those philosophical statements you
can't really appreciate you can't really
appreciate the Sun without the rain and
you can't really appreciate awesome
spring without snow so now that I've had
a winner I'm like really appreciating
what it's like to go outside and have
the weather be nice I'm appreciating the
thought of having spring but it's still
pretty cold here yeah it's been I've
seen your weather one week since you
looked at me it's been oh there's a
greener
it's not too late to go back but yeah
okay let's go I don't think you're
picking up much more stuff there's
probably nothing great about being in a
waste disposal area waste management
they clearly don't watch The Sopranos
[Music]
this looks like something that's gonna
bite me in the butt later so I'm not
gonna pull that yet just trying to look
in that window should I hope should I
turn this thing what thing this e I
don't even know if it'll do anything yet
but you can try okay thanks
they're [ __ ] engineer you all right
or should that know what's that noise
writer I'm freaking out it's been quiet
for too long and they don't put you in
holes for no reason you could make a
full heal now you have a red green blue
yeah and then that gives me a lot more
space also gives you a health boost if
you use it or you lose it I'm not gonna
touch that yeah I was kind of hoping
that there was like an info sheet around
here or am I just supposed to like wing
this yeah okay um this is one of those
where I think you're just better off
yeah pressing buttons and okay I can
tell you this I think they're both
supposed to be in that red area Hey
they should just call it press buttons
until buttons yeah um I hate this this
is like calm before I told you but what
is it well what's it Burke and I think
wait what do I do
wait his hand for now don't let him kill
you hey what are you orange now captain
[ __ ] how does he keep dating me it's
like a whack-a-mole
I think you're fine
wait is he here listen and now to lure
him over and then go through the hole a
dismayed comment you can use that verb
if you'd feel better you have a lot of
health saved up you come
yeah you just want to go through the
hole he just made
so he did hit me christening infant he
hit me again
oh my god he did not die it killed mr.
exploit where's my jump option this is
no time for quick actions I do not
appreciate it
[Music]
what would you say the plan is pause it
quick is the gameplay really loud or is
it just like it on your end I can't tell
the game today is normal you should
lower your audio maybe no no you're fine
I just making sure um so do you want me
to tell you okay so I will say I don't
want to spoil it but this part is one of
my least favorite parts of the remake I
think that's my like just stay alive
right now that's my place yeah how much
you want me to tell you my me just let
you try I can try
I saw an X on that it's already giving
up on Trey like okay I changed my mind
no uh what I saw in it oh it's for ammo
okay all right I got it I just need a
second
it's not going great
it's not there's not a lot of room
[Music]
wait oh I killed myself uh but do you
did that like give you an idea of what
you should do move the container bring
the container back but not be in the way
yeah I didn't know where the container
was going to be it looks like it's off
everywhere it's it's everywhere except
for like near the control panel that
makes sense
but thanks loading screen tip but it's a
sometime
it's very delayed so would you say that
I need to would you say he was he was in
the right spot but yeah you just can't
be there
but I need to hit the button lure him
out here and then go right that's how I
do sort of you [ __ ] you also want to
stun him that'll like prevent him from
alright so I'm running
[ __ ] if he didn't grab me I would have
done it
dumped yeah he grabs your on his hot
seat girl he grabbed me
I wasn't ready because of the grabbing
if he would have I was a close one so
keep in mind I don't know how much you
remember about this boss fight for about
fighting him from the beginning but if
you shoot his eyes enough time he'll
kind of drop to his knees and be stunned
right back I'll pull for this fight so
maybe
he's good I gotta say he's really good
at hitting me got a habit a boy oh come
on I was not in that
[Music]
she [ __ ] a hammer punches that button
cut it
I did it oh wait no I did not do it
again
you got the timing down huh
[Music]
oh he made oh he made wanted to be ready
I hope you can fight me with one's taken
I gotta body is it's out of here get me
out of here mister
[Music]
too loud I'm lowering it to 25 three
shirts
there's Amba on the barrel next to the
control panel or something dude sherry
so dead she's been waiting like ages to
the right of it flashbang I like end up
a little path here yeah convenient how
else would one get to that door I
wouldn't jumped a big old jump so I was
already here but now the now the power
is on and I can do this
I thought Claire was saying that that's
what I thought she has been there for
like three weeks now sherry
Claire Claire sherry Annette sherry oh
Claire oh she looks awful
leave my experiment I made my daughter
alone
how'd you get your daughter hooked on
coke so I can control her watch your
language around my daughter yeah talk to
the hand
wait you think of the voice acting this
game
that's look look into the security cam
sweetheart
kiss kiss the lens that's right the
security cam off she's go where she's
got a baby monitor call me Mommy
call me Theodora sweet sure this'll fun
let's go back to the dump and look for
items Shari step one for it we always go
back to the fridge hey who ate all the
go-gurt wait I will not no this is
actually serious I want to show you
something cool hey who ate all the Hot
Pocket please this is funny for gamers
will really like kept you people under
check my Mountain Dew
[Laughter]
it's for all my gamers out there
[Music]
she's holding that person infected with
a zombie virus dangerously close to her
face but she cares she can drop her like
a hot potato anytime she wants can I
save with this child on me I don't think
so Oh
Lord are hurt where are we going
Oh paying on the thing with Aries but do
I look fine to you [ __ ] my mom turned
off the security cam Claire please shut
up
even like that like at Leon's campaign
you get the bracelet yourself oh really
you ripped it off a dead girl's body off
Sherry's body
there are numerous bracelets within the
mythos god you look so bad I kind of
like I like it it brings out it brings
out your eye wait what
okay never much what I think you got
everything it's just like that's
technically the point of no return for
this part [ __ ] I think you're fine
oh please don't turn into stuff while
I'm on this I gave her the jacket so she
could match it
she's accessorizing dead bodies okay is
this gonna be like an alien situation I
think it's better if you do it like this
you're doing a chest burster sherry
Teddy mm-hmm
what if she comes up Sherry's like
you're in the hot seat girl you're a
zombie no sherry but that's your name
then or Boris or a boss no actually I
want to listen to you but you're [ __ ]
ugly right now bag over your head
sweetie supposed to help with the pain
okay
there's a little trunk here for later or
you could use it now stuff sherry in
there this police I'm gonna pick you up
in a different trunk in a couple hours
trust me these things are like weird
teleporters okay it doesn't make any
sense but we don't question it's cherry
it helped us survive it's like the only
logical thing in this actually there's a
lot of logic
hurry up hurry up hurry up oh no oh I
will
thank you hmm
sign in Cherie Cherie Birkin
purpose of visit DS Amba fication
freaking i purpose of visit I'm [ __ ]
freaking out you should really take a
bath you smell like [ __ ] oh it's me I
feel like we're both pretty dirty yeah
that's gotta be it hey hey Cherie I got
to go
you stay right here though okay you look
good I'll be back soon I promise
oh [ __ ] it's an item why can't I wear it
due to an incident nest personnel are to
immediately use the devil got a shake
the devil out of it
Devils the only way to prevent G
mutation and it's hard to dance with a
devil on your back so check it oh how
they had it do not reply in that email
made it real authentic they're like Gary
we're talking about you do not receive a
reminder of that taco too late the food
in the fridge will be thrown out every
Friday yeah okay um blame around good so
I can save and I can also use an item
box here yeah
which I save II actually first go
double-check that there's nothing back
near the gondola or whatever it was the
thing that you rode down here would it
be on the map no I'm just saying the
just yeah go back through there Sona
make sure because you couldn't pick
anything up with share in your arm so I
just want to make sure we're not missing
anything
Sherry's fighting for her life and I'm
like I wonder if I dropped a grenade
yeah showing those triceps off now I see
that's what I would do
okay I cannot enter this no I know
not genera in this hallway okay it's
blue okay
I gotta say even though it's like
created by the game and it's not real I
always feel a sense of urgency when
someone's sick it like does such a good
job to actually get me to care and want
to continue like if I'm like watching a
show and they're like the dog is ill and
it's got 24 hours to live I'm like well
I have to see how this ends
[Music]
yeah I'm playing the division too and
there are frequent times when it's like
quick they're being tortured and I'm
like okay but first I want to go see if
there's a legendary weapon in this
suitcase you need a higher security
clearance I think oh you only have one
right now
oh here's is that there's this story
anything behind not great is here
you sound like a song they changed the
vibe real quick didn't they all the
matter of lighting and fear
oh no oh no no this reminds me of a
scene before reminds me of the first
scene in dead space
dead space that's awesome you say
there's the scene in dead space where
you see I think like someone died
through this glass or something yeah the
very first time you see an echo more if
you're looking through glass and you
can't do anything about it
did you hear it no I did
I can hear it are you precious hear it
yeah I see him right there couple is it
just a zombie at least two of them maybe
three can they come out of that door I
don't think so
it's like Schrodinger's box for the legs
then just finish them off with a knife
yeah yeah now good never knife
oh right jerk what was that noise was
that him uh I think I saw at least one
other one she's not very good with that
flashlight
he did I killed him II dad I hear him
where is he
so dark in there I'd rather kill him in
this hallway where I know
oh that's bold shut up
all right so I don't think it's a zombie
what else would it be
Constanta it's loudly
should I throw a grenade once in a while
I would I think they're more valuable as
defensive items you can oh I want a
stronger weapon oh it is a zombie don't
worry she's a doctor dr. death where are
you if you close your eyes she won't see
you likes right right in the kisser
shut her arm off
Oh is she dead
this guy's been eating Oh nurse that's a
doctor
hello nurse [ __ ] I hear I hear it I
heard it did you hear it
there's another one there he is what is
this a medical convention damn it
what was that you you cut her jugular I
think it [ __ ] she pooped yourself that's
what happens when you die
hey doctor I'll just smelly oh sorry
that was silly I knew that was a bad
shot but here we are
have we talked about how some of the
zombies are modeled after their
developers yeah this booth tastes good
[Music]
keep knifing him
hey baby yeah he's dead
chop his arm off again look for us
alright we did it that was a lot that
was for yeah whoo coffee
oh man coffee big dope right now
actually no I've said tea that's on the
other side so I can't get it yeah what's
on their menu cheeseburger cheeseburger
big cheese yeah why there's apple pie
spam burger lamb burger shrimp jam
burgers yeah I don't know why I never
knows what cheeseburgers twice it's not
a very good thing to be aware of like
what a cool thing to know oh nice that
pizza [ __ ] I don't see how the chair is
in the way like it's not a chair at the
hot seat those TVs stacked on each other
uh yeah they look like series oh what a
weird ladder in the cafeteria we placed
rod cafeteria to lead to
I've got a gun
well where am I I'm in the kitchen
they're making jam burgers hey what is
that scrambled eggs that looks likes
granby eggs actually those look like
pancakes yeah toast hashmap sausage
those are huge patties I wish like I
think that's a cool job like if you in a
game development and they're like we
need someone to make all the trash like
items that like they're not super
integral but they are valuable in the
sense that without them the game would
not look as immersive as it is and it's
like you got it I'm making flour I'm
making cups I'm making like tea bags
that someone seeped not enough you know
and it's like that's awesome I think
like a look at all these like tiny
little nuanced items that they add to
make sure this area feels real that you
probably won't see anywhere else in the
game and I like it 3d artists I love it
Jam for the jr. burger half hole wait
what that's flour for sure Apple half
hole I'll show you a half hole hey BAE
we're asking for it it's hug you [ __ ]
jerk what yeah you shot him then ran
away that's what you do he doesn't seem
to give a [ __ ] all he's waiting for you
look at him he's like I'm gonna surprise
her I'm gonna get her oh oh my god that
looked creepy I don't have a lot of room
he thought
yeah knife him oh no he's dead it's
wearing armor oh his head is exposed I
think he's dead hey okay what do you
think yeah don't waste a bullet he looks
pretty dead
you can't go through that door anyway
that's a level two security clearance oh
yeah I see it
no he's not dead
[Applause]
dude's got like no face left and he's
alive Oh a chance ashes half of the door
is he dead
I think so are you dead God that
one-armed faceless loser still managed
to get up and almost eat me [ __ ]
unbelievable
mmm it's not a place you want to go
like what happened here aha level 2 is
she is she being punny yeah I think so
that's funny I've never seen an instance
of her being funny before spark shot oh
is that like a compressor for like a
spark shot yeah upgrade all right so I
feel like when I do this shit's gonna go
down probably I don't even think you
could do this yet Moff rude ah you know
what she needs to do I mean it that's
pretty straight up my god
yeah you have level security you have
level two security clearance now so you
can go through that door you know the
other blue one great any blue doorbell
Oh fantastic
he's still dead
wait I have a thing
it's a chip upgraded you gotta combine
it haha Fitbit don't this is back there
oh this is where I killed those people
there's another level two door in the
main lobby
yeah down this way these are all red I
mean the cafeteria is that Oh actually
needle cartridges
what's a needle cartridge it's Fitz Park
shot other side of the door I think yeah
there's some sort of fan on your end
it's not a huge deal but it's maybe the
window no it's my computer that's fine
yeah so the level 2 door is that red one
on the bottom side or bottom right
hopefully it's not too loud on the old
my Kirino hey that's me
the NAB room no not that accompanied the
red door bottom right
oh that yeah was I not able to go in
here
well yeah you were just in there that's
where you got the circuit breakers yeah
but you need the muff thing or whatever
it is don't be rude the muf thing sorry
this is a safe area I feel like because
it's got us right I think I should save
what do you think I'm caught right yeah
probably just like screaming into the
void doctor should I check on that
sherry hey you want to visitor general
senior why did [ __ ] no nevermind oh the
NAP room log
Toby been napping Sarah been napping
Walt definitely napping
what says when they left there's
probably someone there that hasn't left
yet Wayne that's his ID Ben you're using
oh you sleepy boy he's probably not a
zombies just using this whole thing as
an excuse to get a few winks hide out
here to save all of you uh you go those
masks over his eyes he's listening to
like ocean wave sounds ripping a fat
bong
my name is not ghost it's Steve Rogers
oh wait his name is Roger are they
saying Roger saying Roger
my name's not Craig
antiviral agents in the West area
that's all this tech for a massive
square button look at this this is so
Star Wars or a res evil five
so she said you're ultimately trying to
get to the west area area no she said
West I thought but yeah you got to go to
East first because West is like a level
three security clearance
there's like crazy fragmenting on the
walls here yeah I see it
I don't like this
it's just nothing it's just like a weird
cardboard I guess a table or the ceiling
panel hello is anybody home yeah it's
too quiet you know what I mean
nope - I should have put something in
one of the boxes I'm like full dude wrap
you want around here actually I don't
think there is there's a say oh the best
guide in the West I said there was one
there and then I took it back but I
still said there was one there well I
have three knives so that's easy and
then I probably does well shower right
now
Wyatt could probably you could upgrade
the spark shot right now
I'll give you that one flame grenade
either right Wow looks like a dead space
gun I want to play a dead space at
timesplitters gun I slept on that game
I've played pieces of it dead space
yeah I never committed I like never
they're some of my favorite games
I just never committed to the series I
like there was nothing wrong with it I
have no excuse
I just stupid it was just stupid
so dumb yeah you could say if you want I
don't think you did I said oh yeah I'm
just you might as well
I wish they'd go with such a shiny
material here it's so uh it just looks
really bad etienne on it
Oh what the [ __ ] is that
oh my god
that's awful
that's a scientist who got squished
against the glass by a plant yeah kinky
[ __ ] wild
what a cool visual oh I think pulse oh
there's that purple wristband he's got
senior staff oh yeah it's in his hand
it's so obvious mm-hmm that's really
good
this game is very good it's like oh gee
I wonder what I'm supposed to do next
Oh looks like there's a guy with a
[ __ ] super day just [ __ ] dick and I
wonder if like well yeah like I did not
go peacefully into that good glass the
family is like did he have pain and the
doctors like oh yeah still in anguish oh
this like I'm saying this is like top
five most painful deaths you could
imagine I can feel it just telling you
about it he was actually screaming
please please this is the most painful
thing any human has ever experienced a
good 15 minutes the bathroom and took a
poop and came back and he was still
alive screaming I mean I really had to
go
am I gonna fight this plant that feels
like it you remember the the original
game yes I fought a plant in the first
game - did I have a flamethrower though
that thing is alive we know it together
actually [ __ ] wait shoot those yellow
things on him he's got those little
yellow pods this is those things what
are they called
they're kind of like you're killing the
same way as regenerators from four
where's his last pod Adam these dudes
are actually easier to kill than regular
zombies cuz you can actually see where
their crit spots
this is [ __ ] awful also I'm really
close to running out of bullets are you
sure I shouldn't like you're fine you
got 42 submachine gun rounds
where is it
he's making that is that your [ __ ]
dick yes all right nice yeah what yeah I
about using the submachine gun now wait
what what kind of gunpowder is that top
right and what is the other one you have
make sense but I don't have that much
ammo just don't like fire it all you
need is one bullet per weak spot just
don't hold it just like shoot it in
short bursts god that's [ __ ] gross
have you seen annihilation yes
reminds me of that I'm not gonna spoil
anything with I didn't like that film it
was okay
are you messing with are you saying that
because you know I love it I know you
love it but I'm not saying it to piss
you off I just didn't think it was that
great fair enough
it was a little obtuse yeah well so am i
but I bet the book was good I heard
that's what was really good
I liked the trilogy well I liked the
first and last books the middle ones
kind of boring I don't want to touch
that yet I feel uncomfortable I don't
want to touch that yet I feel
uncomfortable and I don't want to go out
that door I'm feeling comfortable hello
riots everywhere hey um I have a gun
doesn't have a lot of bullets Winky
blinky okay I need a code that looks
like Star Wars [ __ ] like that's what
they're all they're panels on the Death
Star looks like very Tetris II okay
I think there's probably I'm sure
there's a name for that script that I'm
not remembering some kind of tube hey if
you're watching this hit me up on
Twitter with what that's worth
wait the end if [ __ ] you just watered it
it works now you don't know what I'm
doing
i watered the plants
I don't want to [ __ ] be in here are
you sure I have enough weapons yeah I
don't feel good about this at all
Oh Lord okay it's a map
if I go to the right there's a war dead
like a dead end
what sorry I might mess my mic up all
right so this is a dead end
yes because of the Ritz it's Carlton
do you like rooks crackers what's that
that's a plan
that's a ritzy looking car what are mine
are you telling me not to shoot this guy
despite you already shot twice now I'm
just saying you don't need to he was you
can dodge these dudes I don't want to
they're awful
do you hear the music when they got it
might have one more yeah it's on his
heart I think we just let him come
closer don't risk wasting bullets well
he's not coming closer it's not eliris
don't bait yourself I don't like being
BAE
you're an expert fader masters stop
racing oh I don't have enough ammo
you don't yeah you could okay
yeah go gun here collect then whatever
is in here
there's a grenade next to him no big no
herbicide killing plants do you ever
give up
matricide synthesis - hey machine
oh is this the solution el opposite el
eye is that what that is
I mean it's worn off I think you need
more information but yes sort of I'll
write it down on one of my mental
notepads
it lets you pick if you want to ignore
contemplate stick somewhere do something
about do you know the person that made
those no wait I know the person who gave
it to me cuz it was a gift is that what
you know no all right it's got some goo
in there so he'll cha that's a big human
looks like he pooped so much that it
filled up the rest of his alright is
there anything else it's red oh that's
because of the large gunpowder I saw
that
we're in the middle
um so I can make bullets with this I
just like you know yeah I would go back
to the save room and you have a lot of
my you can make know that you just need
to come here to make the chemical I just
don't feel comfortable
they just make like gross noises oh he's
moved no no I'm in a different spot what
I thought he thought they moved you got
using a secret name or a regular grenade
yeah actually I would use that equip it
then hold l1 to aim and throw it with
what are to make sure you throw it at
there yeah nice I think they got him
yeah there guy dad yeah nice perfect
do the [ __ ] bowling ball music in
this scene it's not cool at all like
super [ __ ] up really stressful music I
want to save it there and then start a
next episode by making Amma I mean it's
been one full hour so we could yeah I
think I want to make mo right now so you
have you just got your second double
let's let's store everything and then I
can show you what I got show you what I
got okay
like look at all this [ __ ] I don't think
you need that red and green herb either
but look at all this [ __ ] like I want to
use some I'm trying to remember your
coming up I'm like in regular zombies in
a little bit and the group looking guys
so you probably I mean at the very least
yeah handgun ammo would be good like
ready to regular gunpowder's
and maybe a little bit more this guy
yeah ya know cuz you only have to hide
oh you have three um yeah maybe
submachine gun mo and then use the third
for the combined with a regular four do
it yeah yeah so two of those together
yeah now back out and come actually no
no yeah whatever
combine all those good that's submachine
gun you should reload both those guns
just so you have full clips the sobs are
gonna get after the a I would just keep
both of us Aoife submachine gun okay now
do a high-grade and a large gunpowder
that should give you like six acid
rounds
and then you can combine those think
yeah that's actually really good
maybe there's no way I don't think to
double your submachine gun rounds yeah
then just you in that case you could um
the reason is is because I combined a
regular gun powder with one of the large
ones why that'll give you there's two
handgun rounds I think yeah I know but
if you come by am not using weight
actually what would be more helpful a
large gun powder and a regular actually
yeah I would just cuz then I'll have
like 50 bullets and I think I'll feel a
lot better okay
yeah just due to regular gunpowder's
make sense but if you combine a large
gun powder and a regular you'll get
double the handgun rounds will I but
well I want the large later and can I
use the large for anything else actually
yeah that's what I'm saying I think you
should save it for double acid rounds
cuz I don't need that I just want my
bullets right now that's all
okay I think you're in good okay I feel
better okay save ooh
that area is scary I don't like it plant
42 it's called
well we'll attack the plant God next
week Gaia Gaia
oh that's I think that's the Titan or
God of Earth I don't know I've got a
brush up in my apology intro um yeah I
remember those guys from the first one
and they were absolutely terrifying
because of the way they moved and stuff
they kind of like they have that like
gross humanoid thing going on and I hate
it so much like Groot but now
cute yes Groot is a minion what you know
those like little yellow minions that
are yeah I know what do you mean he'd
some in you think that's like the only
purpose he serves yeah by that by that
then like Gimli is a minion as well
Gimli that's like just comic relief
qualifies you as a minion then I'm a
minion in this in this show that we've
been doing for three years haha I don't
know how to do a minute sweet well yeah
that was good you sound like one you
could be the [ __ ] minion sweet cool
have fun in San Francisco thanks um we
will see you guys again on the next
episode of Resident knievel don't forget
to Like and subscribe so we can keep
making this stuff and hit us up on
Twitter with any questions and
definitely like any fan art or any fun
stuff you have to show us we like to see
it join the discord Nathan Shepard oh
actually we got it actually you know
yeah that's what I'm gonna do really
quick we look up stats because we
haven't done that in a few let's do it
let me find the last episode what is
this the 10th episode of season yeah I
record them so I should have a log on my
the one we just this tonight is number
10 that makes sense
7 8 9 this is 10 you're right I know I'm
right I'm on whoa that was loud sorry um
and there we go okay Nathan Shepard our
diligent stat taker was I say okay first
that's how many deaths do you think you
had okay so wait hold on today you had
two deaths because of the boss fight
total including those two how many do
you think you have oh so you're adding
the deaths from today yeah
I don't think I've died that much
honestly I'm gonna say ten including
today you only have five you had three
of course I'm killing it
oh but remember yeah but we also we
weren't counting uh the actually no yeah
cuz in the in the orphanage sherry
didn't die he just threw her back in the
room sure there's three saves today with
today you've like 36 but I we kind of
saved a little early today chewed on by
zoms
six times 56 kills today you had another
including William yet William for
zombies five six of those group things
so like 11 like 67 kills and yeah also
top comment from Nathan Shepard if
you're new to the show he has the
discord link we have a resident Knievel
discord where all the fans hang out and
share fan art and talk about a bunch of
them are playing through this game and
other games in the series and talking
about their favorite moment so go join
that if you frequent the show or if it's
your first time welcome Nathan thank you
as always and yeah mm hmm
I haven't I haven't I've been reading
comments as much this season I should
try to get back to that even though
we're on episode 10 okay and wait you
guys on the next episode thank you for
hanging out with us and is this your job